Nicole is with us in Washington hi
Nicole welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Jane thanks I think taking my call
hi so my parents have decided to be
extremely generous and have gifted me
one hundred fifty eight thousand dollars
in stocks
Wow their mixture yeah I know very nice
so I want to do the right thing with it
um it's about half Microsoft half contra
fund I think it's the name of them and
I'm wondering what to do with the money
I have no debt I have a pretty good
salary i fund my 401k and my Roth and
then I have some additional mutual funds
as well I'm thinking about buying a
house however I know that you I know
that you teach to have a 15% sixth grade
or sorry 15-year fixed-rate mortgage and
put 20% down however that would be more
than a quarter of my take-home pay for
my mortgage mortgage payment um so would
you suggest putting more than 20% down
and using that that gifted stock money
or maybe some of my other mutual fund
money in order to have a larger down
payment to get down me the monthly
mortgage payment it sounds like you have
no use for this money I would use it all
on the house okay okay and then let's
get about the business of paying off the
house as your last step your foot you're
out of debt you have an emergency fund
you're funding a retirement and let's
get the house paid off okay sounds good
to me now drop a second your parents
have gotten legal advice and tax advice
on this yep they have they talked to
their financial person they talked to my
financial person I'm sure there's a
reason why they they're doing a unified
they're doing a unified estate tax
unified estate tax credit right I don't
know the answer to that unified estate
tax credit I'm not sure it's the only
way they can transfer one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to you without
paying taxes give big butt gift tax on
it
oh they would have to pay I guess if
they don't use what I just said they
will pay a huge gift tax on this okay I
think they've avoided that because we
did go around and make sure that we were
doing this then most economical and yeah
you're when you sell this stuff you will
pay capital gains tax on anything over
there basis meaning what they paid for
this one hundred fifty eight thousand
not what it's worth but what they paid
for it is their basis the difference in
that and 158 is taxable to you when you
sell it okay do you know what the tax
rate is on that Assisting percent okay
so I just need to make sure to put aside
that amount do you know do you know what
the basis is in these ones I don't I
have the documents at home okay
yeah and so if let's just pretend it was
yeah so if it was fifty-eight thousand
and the gain is a hundred thousand and
the gain would be taxable at fifteen
percent it cost you fifteen grand as an
example okay okay you can see your tax
and professional your financial
professional to help you make sure you
get that all right but net of taxes I
would throw it all at this house and
then I get the house paid off as fast as
I can
what is your income ninety two thousand
five hundred that's before tax how old
are you 32 well done you are killing it
thank you
and they opted and they obviously have
killed it right yeah what a great legacy
that reminds me of you well I'm honored
that's very cool because obviously he's
done a great job raising you number one
and number two did a great job with the
money so it's compliment to be set up if
I'm anything like him that's awesome